the Oscar goes to Dame Judy
Den
um I feel for8 minutes um on the screen
uh I should only get a little bit of him
um I do thank the academy very much
indeed uh I do think also that the best
bit about the Academy Awards is being
nominated um you live in a kind of haze
for several weeks um and the terrible
thing is that somebody's got to win my
heart get out to all the other four who
didn't and my also my admiration I do
have to thank John Madden uh and Tom
stard and Mark Norman as I actually
wrote to John Madden after Mrs Brown and
said I will do anything in your next
film um if you want somebody to slouch
in a doorway you can count on me um and
I mean it and I hope he Bears me in mind
next time I do thank you all very much
indeed I'm very moved by it